[музика]
у хасидському кварталі Умані починається
свято до юдейського Нового року
рошгашана ще кілька днів Але до міста
попри війну вже прибули тисячі
паломників кожен хасид хоча б раз у
житті має відвідати ось це місце могилу
садика тобто праведника рабі нахмана
більшість часу віряни моляться
сподіваючись на прощення гріхів
А ще танцюють і співають як заповідав
рабінахман він говорив що треба радіти
Спілкуючись з Богом заповіді садика для
хасидів священні і непорушні навіть у
часи війни я їхав тому що арабінах
сказав війна Не війна це однаково магія
Я приїхав до цадика рабі нахмана до
Умані
святкувати Рош гашана Я сподіваюся що в
Умані все пройде добре і Проблем не буде
і завжди буде тільки ми
А ви ж піст в Україні Миру що більше не
було війни щоб весь світ жив у мирі а
Україна знову повернулася до нормального
життя
цьогоріч над входом до могили цадика
заклик молитися за Україну за радянської
влади це місце було під приватною
забудовою а паломництво хасидів
заборонялося Тож до Росії як спадкоємці
СРСР віряни традиційно ставляться
негативності
Слава Україні зазвичай у хасидському
кварталі жінки не бажані вважаються що
вони відволікають чоловіків від молитви
але цьогоріч на вулицях можна зустріти і
хасидок чимало паломників їхали за
кілька тижнів до свята бо побоювалися що
Україна закриє кордони А щоб не
розлучатися з родиною брали з собою
дружин і дітей так і нахман з Єрусалима
приїхав З усією сім'єю
[музика]
ми молимося їм Ми купуємо деякі речі а в
основному молимося і молимося
Ми не боїмося чому нам не страшно ми
приїхали до Ради нас захищає люди іноді
вмирають але вони не обирають Коли їм
померти Бог обирає поліція і місцева
Влада цьогоріч не розголошують кількості
паломників орієнтовно прибудуть до 10
тисяч людей утричі менше ніж торік на
час святкування запровадили додаткові
обмеження від 19 вересня і по 30 вересня
діє заборона на продаж алкогольних
слабоалкогольних напоїв також продаж
піротехнічних виробів предметів схожих
на зброю також обмежили паркування у
районі паломництва
всі хто прибувають проходять ретельно
перевірку Хай їм хасид який уже 10 років
живе в Умані участь
українську мову добре розумію говорю
трохи
Хай їм власник крамниці і готелю
навпроти спочатку війни його бізнес
простоював чоловік розповідає Що у
своєму готелі безкоштовно поселяв
українських військових а автомобіль
швидкої допомоги який придбав для
єврейської громади передав ЗСУ нині в
готелі хайма усі номери заброньовані
хасиди дуже пов'язані з Україною тому що
хасидизм починався в Україні наші корені
звідси І ми відчуваємо себе дуже
близькими до цієї землі і ніхто не
забере нас звідси війна Не війна не
завжди сюди приїдемо
на дворі у центрі хасицького кварталу
чекає на орендарів підприємець Станіслав
він власник апартаментів просто навпроти
могили цадика нахмана кімната в цьому
будинку на один тиждень коштує півтори
тисячі доларів підприємець певен що
паломників більше лякав ковід ніж війна
тож цьогоріч сподівається на непоганий
прибуток можна по-різному відноситись
але я більше бачу плюсів чи мінусів так
як реально
країна зараз під час війни нічого не ну
якби не заводить кошти ніякі не
производив нічого тобто
із іншого світу привозять люди гроші і
тратять їх і і місцеві жителі щось
питаються заробити і потім бабушки які
живуть тут здають квартири вони без
пенсії можуть півроку жити водночас
підприємець визнає українцям складно
конкурувати з хасидами які викуповують
житло в цьому кварталі паломники більш
охоче селяться в одновірців до того ж
хасиди часто привозять з собою навіть
продукти а в Умані витрачають не так
багато коштів заступник міського голови
Умані Олег ганіч додає що місто на
організацію паломництва витрачає більше
ніж заробляє не допомагає навіть
туристичний збір який з цього року можна
сплатити онлайн до сьогоднішнього дня от
за цим посиланням сплатили тільки 7
чоловік цього туристичного збору тобто
якщо місто орієнтовно на 10 тисяч
паломників несе затратну частину порядка
мільйона гривень на прибирання вулиць на
вивіз мусору і так далі і тому подібне
то на сьогодні сплачено тільки там е-е
Сім чоловік по 1300 грн це получається
10,000 грн грубо кажучи більшість
уманчан до щорічного паломництва звикли
але до приїзду хасидів під час війни
ставляться по-різному вони різкують
своїм здоров'ям і напружують нашу
обстановку і не стоїло б їм в цьому році
приїжджати як на мене на цьому нікуди не
дінемося це їхня релігія і цей
ми не вибирали цього якщо вони вважають
що вони відчайдухи і можуть в країну
воюють воюючу приїхати не бояться то це
їхній вибір Вікторія і Наталя
переселенка з Миколаєва після постійних
обстрілів Вдома вони вважають Умань
безпечним містом і для себе і для
приїжджих вірян Ну якщо їм дозволили
наша влада сюди приїхати то якось вони
там у своєму кварталі хай собі
це їх свято
Ми якось нормально до цього відносимось
і Ізраїль і офіційний Київ радили
паломникам цьогоріч утриматися від
поїздки в Україну адже гарантувати
безпеку від російських ракет не може
ніхто і все ж у цій синагозі готуються
до одночасної молитви кількох тисяч
людей на свято рожана тут облаштовані
укриття в підвалах де розташовані мікви
тобто бані синагогою опікується
благодійний фонд імені рабінахмана
керівник фонду на танбенун не згоден із
рекомендаціями не їхати до Умані Бо
вважає місто безпечним 24 лютого він сам
був в Ізраїлі але в березні повернувся в
Україну
весілля
і бачать мирну вулицю звісно йде війна
але всі дотримуються правил а життя має
тривати
Ізраїль з 1948 року у стані війни
але ми живемо
чому ж не приїжджати
Ізраїль не закриває кордонів усі
приїжджають і виїжджають
надвечір на колишній вулиці Пушкіна А
віднедав на туристичній більш людно
ловники ходять до безкоштовних їдалень
спілкуються купують книжки грають у
футбол невдовзі почнеться комендантська
година за словами правоохоронців У цей
час вулиці порожніють маленький
український Ізраїль дотримується правил
воєнного часу